alors stéphane comment tu te sors mon
chéri bon écoute sa vache en bonne
compagnie ces jeunes avantage alors mon
chéri c'est très simple est ce que vous
voulez venir sur le plateau
nabila et stéphane stéphane je savais
que tu es un aventurier chez que d'un
sportif on a déjà joué au tennis
ensemble si près 6 0 c'est pas grave tu
es sera pas le seul
[Rires]
mais non c'est pas vrai ce n'est pas
elle était très fatiguée sur la il fera
pas parce que je sais quand avait bossé
d'ouf attention les chéris je vais vous
poser des questions de culture générale
il va falloir répondre à 5 questions et
pour pouvoir sortir ou la 28 ça dans la
bagnole et moi je savais pas c'est que
moi ça va mais abidal est la l1 ça alors
forcément quand la voiture va tourner et
vous allez vous le prouvent les preneurs
mal et tous regardent passer l'oral ses
animateurs pékin est fraîche et à une
panne motus
non mais c'est dur alors là non c'est
pas dur t'inquiète pas on a trouvé ça
dans le slip de benjamin castaldi
gratuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention les chéris c'est parti sa
tournée au liban
la place saint gillois je sors je dois
la village tous pensent qu'une question
que tu répondes le footsie [ __ ] de jeu
labida si tu réponds bien c'est bon de
quel papa j'ai même pas l'oreillette
j'ai même pas vrai merde stéphane va te
poser la question vas-y jetez plus la
question de quel arbre le clan est il le
fruit le oui de quel arbre blanc est il
le fruit
depuis quand ça vous sur les armes et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez quoi les attentions à petite
ou une habile à céret pont gars alors
pour toi entre avait pourtant encore toi
aussi tu remets narration cheryl
la remette à saturne à bin hammam et à
ceinture mais j'aimais les mesures à
adacore devait la vie de m'accrocher la
tension est accroché si tu as combien
cette question depuis toujours que je
vais vous poser après un petit tour est
ce qu'il est un petit détour avec la
ceinture à l'âme est bien meilleure amie
on la vit on l'a mis à l attaque qui
compteront sur un bitume et attention
nabila juin l'otan du tout non pour
réfléchir qu'elle en fait de la vente du
système solaire à tanger pas entendu
telle est la plus
je suis comme toi à est là je pense que
stéphane est ce que tu m'as quelle est
la plus grosse planète du système
solaire
saturne sorcière masse nabila nabila ben
voilà c'est bon de la ceinture à tanger
avait sûr je remets la lumière complète
ce proverbe mieux vaut être seul que mal
renvoyé un seul but vrai le seul que mal
foutu complète
mieux vaut être seul que mal quel mal
accompagné d'un gardien
[Applaudissements]